hello everyone and welcome to the game
that just ended it's a game from the
penultimate round of the magnus carlsen
invitational preliminaries uh daniel
dubo versus magnus carlsen uh the two
rivals are brawling it out once again
and the the this game features a
most impressive style of play but that's
nothing out of the ordinary when uh
dooba is playing uh well either color uh
and of course uh in any time format so
without further ado let's check it out
as this is uh
this is uh uh something else so and it's
very interesting
uh that uh going into this game duval it
has
six points whereas magnus has nine and a
half points so magnus is not really in
any
uh danger of dropping out but the double
uh should should
definitely try and grab as many points
as possible in the next two games so
duba with
the white pieces uh opens with d4
uh we have d5 by magnus c4 by do wolf
and now
c6 are going uh for the slav defense
we have knight to f3 knight to f6 and
now
knight the c3 uh we have e6 by magnus
are going for the semi slav
and now g3 preparing to fiance to the
light square bishop we have knight b to
d7
uh just continuing development and the
bishop to g2
uh we have d captures on c4 magnus grabs
upon here
maybe he will uh try and try even in the
defendant with b5 later on
and the doom of castles and now while
you can play b5 and this is definitely
playable
magnus goes for a different line bishop
to d6 and um
he asks this duba what do you play here
duba a big fan of rapid development
continues with bishop to g5 pins the
knight here
and h6 now magnus forces him to either
move or or capture on f6 you don't have
of course
h4 because g5 is happening so bishop
captures on f6 queen captures on f6
now uh there is a game where rook to c1
was played but here
we have knight to d2 by magnus going aft
uh by dub of going after the c4 pawn
uh and it is as a move tender we have a
completely new game so let's see how
magnus deals with this he starts with uh
knight to b6 just defending that c4 pawn
uh and a4 now dooba tries to kick away
the knight with a5 magnus prevents it he
pushes a5 himself
and now knight c to e4 attacking the
queen
and the bishop here we have queen back
to e7
and now even b3 uh so
what do you play here of course magnus
captures we have c captures on b3
uh knight captures on d6 now eliminating
this strong dark square bishop
queen captures and even queen captures
on b3 duval doesn't even try
and defend the d for pawn you could play
e3 you could play knight captures and b3
to defend the pawn but duplo goes queen
captures on b3
and he sacrifices yet another pawn and
magnus grabs it queen captures on d4
and now if you do a quick count magnus
has seven pawns dubo has uh
five and the the good question is uh
where's the dubose compensation
uh does he have some sort of an attack
does he have some huge lead in
development
and he kind of does magnus has this
weird knight on b6 but it's coming
to d5 so it's not a problem uh one thing
you have to
be careful of is how are you gonna
develop your light square bishop and if
you can't develop the light square
bishop you can't
very well bring the rook into the game
uh so here rook f2d1 by double now
preparing some nasty discoveries after
the knight moves
uh but there aren't uh any that are all
that nasty so first uh we have just
castles by magnus uh rook ate the b1
now putting pressure on the knight but
just knight to d5 as planned
and now knight to c4 and dubo has a very
firm grip on the position
if that uh knight comes to comes to b6
you can completely
uh blockade the position uh the light
square bishop will not be able
to enter the game uh the the rooks will
not be able to connect and it's going to
be very hard for magnus to play this
so instead we have queen to c3 and
magnus immediately offers a queen trade
and
now e4 by dubaf uh we have queen
captures on b3
rook captures on b3 and now knight to b4
and magnus cuts off the rook's influence
on the b file and
do both advances this pawn to e5 uh
which means this bishop now comes alive
and these pawns are locked in on light
squares so yeah you want to keep this
light square bishop locked in and it
seems like uh
you might think wow google is really
playing some really really insane uh
impressive chess because there is that
uh one alpha zero game if you guys
remember we covered it on the channel
where
uh alpha zero sacrificed uh two pawns uh
against stockfishtalk which was playing
the queen's indian defense
and completely locked in the slight
square bishop stock which was helpless
and in the end alpha zero just
crushed him but here dubo actually has
only six minutes on the clock some six
minutes and 20 seconds whereas magnus
has almost
13 minutes on the clock so uh it doesn't
seem like magnus is
struggling all that much with with this
position and it's
it seems like he knows what he's doing
so here we have knight to d5
bringing the knight back to this
excellent square and now f4 by dubo now
getting this
very nice pawn chain here but now b5 and
this is the move that magnus planned out
uh he sacrifices the pawn back to open
up the position
as now his bishop can come alive and it
also comes with a little tactic because
if pawn captures pawn captures which was
played in the game
there is the option of rook captures on
b5 but
dubo doesn't go for this even though uh
you could but
it's it's very dangerous for example
rook captures on b5
uh bishop to a6 now with an attack on
the rook and the knight and now you
sacrifice the exchange rook captures we
have
e captures on d5 and now you pick up the
a5 pawn so duboff could get
this position in but he's never grabbing
this pawn because after the bishop moves
the knight is under attack and now you
have to play something knight b3 or b7
probably b7 and then you defended the
pawn like this and
now the game could continue for example
bishop captures
bishop captures rook captures but now
rook f2 b8 and
it's a very very uh tough position to
play for white white will be up upon
but still the the rook pair here uh will
simply be too strong
so well this is a one possibility duba
of course avoids this he plays bishop
captures on d5
and now we have e captures on d5 uh
sorry e captures on the five grabbing
back the the piece we have knight to b6
now uh and here we have rook to a6
again this was one moment where magnus
could have played the bishop to g4 and
this is a very scary move to face
uh because uh the the rook is under
attack and after rook captures on d5
magnus just continues pushing a4 now
attacking the rook on b3
and after you grab this pawn for example
now you play rook to a6
and you don't really have a good way of
dealing with this the pawn is marching
down the board the other rook
is coming to v8 and there there's really
nothing to do if rook to b1
uh this rook cannot go back the bishop
covers the d1 square so
you could play something like this but
then rook to b8 and this will be too
much to handle if rook d to b5
defending just a3 and then a2 and that's
that's game
so this is one way to do it for magnus
but he plays rook to a6
and now uh dubo gets a new wind
here in his back we have knight captures
rook captures and now
rook captures on b5 so this is what
magnus wanted
he wanted to give back some material so
he can start pushing his past pawn so a4
and now rook d captures rugby rook d
captures
on d5 grabbing that pawn now we have a3
here magnus continues pushing
and now rook to a5 duke of cuts off
carlson's rook here
and uh it's a very very tricky position
uh there's only one good move here for
magnus so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find
this only good move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not playing rook c to c6 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the move is actually
rook 8 to a8 so this is what you have to
do
because after this move now you're just
uh yeah well you're just basically
winning there's not much you can do the
pawn is marching forward
uh and for example if let's say captures
captures there is no stopping the spawn
rook d1
a2 rook a1 okay you can't stop it but
now the rook is stuck on a1 and the
black is
free to just bring the king into the
game and the rook will for example come
to a3 completely cut off the white king
and it's it's a winning endgame
but here after rook to a5 magnus went to
rook c to c6
but now it's a bit different because
dubo finds a a beautiful
moves that saves him and that's rook to
d8 with check we have king to h7 and now
rook to a8 so this is how do with tricks
magnus
uh with rook capture 78 rook capture is
now attacking the a3 pawn
and first rook the c1 with check king g2
and now
rook to c2 with check king of three and
only now a2
so for the moment you don't have to
worry because there's no way for the
rook to reach the back ring to defend
the queening square but magnus will need
to keep the rook there in order to
defend the past pawn so here
we have f5 not worrying about the h2
pawn double wants to play e6 and create
a pass pawn of his own
so rook captures on h2 and now e6
do both creates a pass pawn uh we have f
captures
f captures and now rook to h1 ah this is
a necessity uh by magnus
uh because if you do nothing then the
pawn is just queening you don't have
rook to e2 because the king covers that
so
magnus needs to part with the a2 pawn
and he plays it
rook to h1 uh we have rook captures on
a2 and now rook to e1 putting the rook
behind the pass pawn
and now rook to a6 defending we have
king to g6
and now we have g4 uh you could try this
check but it doesn't really do anything
just king to f7 and the pawn is now
attacked twice so that doesn't really
work so after king to g6 we have g4 by
dooba
and now king to f6 going after the pawn
here
king to g3 and now rook to e3 with check
king f2 and only now rook captures on uh
on e6 and now well you could play this
position in a lot of very different ways
uh duba
finds of course the the fanciest way to
continue and that is
g5 with check of course the king cannot
capture because you lose the rook so you
have to double your pawns
and now h captures and g5 we get this
position where
black has doubled pawns uh and white
will of course try
try and hold this uh even though black
is up two pawns
you can't even though the pawns are
double you cannot trade if you trade the
position is winning for black just in
case you were wondering
uh so rook to a2 and now we continue
king f5 with king f3
again in the opposition g4 check we have
king to g3
uh rook to e3 with check king to f2 we
have rook to f3 with
chuck king g2 and now king the g5 uh
rook to a8 and now rook to b3
uh we have rooked the a2 again
preventing any checks on the second rank
king to h4 now uh rook the c2
and now rook to b8 uh dubo just waits uh
he has to wait for magnus to push all of
all of his pawns
upwards and then he's gonna create some
sort of uh stalemating pattern or or
whatnot
so here rook back to a2 he's just
repeating moves and rook the c8
so magnus would probably agree to a draw
of course magnus realizes that dubo
knows this is a draw the problem is
uh magnus has uh 15 minutes on the clock
whereas duvet has only 30 seconds on the
clock and maybe who knows
now with 30 seconds on the clock
anything can happen like you could
uh you could you know do a mouse slip
you could you know
forget about the time you could uh you
could get disconnected
maybe even for a few seconds and that's
going to be a lot since you only have 30
seconds
so uh it you know definitely pays you to
try so here look back to b2
and rook to a8 now we have rook to c2
just waiting to see what happens
rook to a for now we have rook to b2 and
now
g3 finally a pawn move we have rook to
c2 and now
rook to f4 we have rook to c7
going after the pawn here and now rook
to f2 check it's not a problem king g1
and now
g6 by magnus uh we have rooked the c6
again going after the pawn
g5 and now rook to h6 with
check uh we have king to g4 here and
rook back to h8 so
the king is cut off from uh from
reaching the the h
file we have rook to e2 and now rook
back to a8
uh we have rooked the e4 and now king to
g2
gaining the opposition you don't want to
the king getting any closer
so rook to f4 and now king back to g1 we
have rook to f2
and again rook to a7 just wasting a move
we rook the e2 that's not e2 rook to e2
and
now rook back to a8 we have g2 finally
the pawn reaches this square
and now rook to a3 cutting off the black
king from
reaching deeper into the position we
have king f4 and now rook to b3 keeping
control of the third rank and
now rook the e3 magnus finally offers a
rook trade
and the problem here is uh you might be
thinking why not something like
g for g3 and then we hide the king on h3
and while that is a valid idea
uh it's only a valid as an idea because
white would just waste a move after g3
that white would win that pawn rook
captures on g3 and you cannot recapture
because it's still mated the white king
now has no move so that's basically
uh the idea or rather the the trick
behind how you
how you uh not lose this position
so rook the e3 magnus goes about it like
this with rook capture scheme captures
and now king captures on g2 and now
magnus is up a pawn
but it is a position that well does not
allow black to push for more than a draw
so king f4
magnus will of course try to move is
very low on time but it's also fun to
you know play the game
up out until the last possible move
g4 we have king g2 g3 king g1 king to g4
now king g2 again grabbing opposition
king h4 king g2 uh
king g2 not king h1 king h3 and now king
to h1 again grabbing opposition
g to check king g1 and after king to g3
uh this
is now of course stalemate and the game
ends in a draw
in some 77 moves so really a a really uh
feisty game uh duboff uh
played in great style again uh right
from the beginning the the game
definitely reminded me of that uh
one game alpha zero played against
stockfish where uh
the the entire queen side was just
completely cut off but magnus obviously
saw that game and he decided to give
back the b-pawn to activate his pieces
so
uh there you have it that's how you
that's how you play and
if not for that movie it'd be it would
be uh
impossible to play because the white
would simply grab too much space so with
this b5
uh with this b5 idea let me just uh uh
rewind
that a little bit yeah here well this b5
idea such a such a strong move such an
impressive move uh that shows
that even though you're up two points
you don't need two points you need to
get backed upon activate the pieces and
then
enjoy your extra pass pawn that you know
should have won the game but
i i think magnus wasn't all that much
into this game because he's
already leading uh by by you know a huge
margin
uh and he's qualifying into the the main
event without
any problems so i guess his heart just
wasn't
in this one but it also shows you what
uh what it means to play against someone
who plays as aggressive and as
complex as daniel lou of here uh so
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it could have ended uh you know
any in any way possible but in the end
in the end
in a draw so hope you enjoyed this one
uh i would like to thank henry almei
scott melissa locust ocaries dale lear
and vessel and welch
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
and yeah thank you all for watching uh i
will see you soon
uh with some uh with some more of the
good stuff from this tournament
uh see you soon